the show VP which terrific program via
and you got a chance to play the host of
The Tonight Show that's right on veep
like sort of a generic host of the yeah
like alternate universe host of The
Tonight Show yeah I did that once a bit
longer than then I did not much longer
did you lie I'm just curious when you
were in the role as an actor of
talk-show host
did you get a feel for what that job
would be like did you like being a
talk-show host when you were doing it
yeah I think so I think it mostly it was
just super easy afterwards like
afterwards I was like why is it like
it's just an empty stupid feeling no I
could even though it was fake it was I
could tell it was so hard it must be so
hard to like the thing that I was
thinking about was like having to keep
the ball in the air when there's a
incredibly boring guest do you know what
that might be like
I don't know it's never a grounder to
guess who wasn't an absolute delay right
okay well I know I had a moment with
Martin Short was on the show and he's
always amazing yes such a fantastic
guest and then he moved down the couch
and he was sitting where Andy sitting
now and this actress came on the show
and she was talking and she didn't have
a lot to say she hadn't prepared any
stories and I'm really trying and then
at one point I don't know what to say
and I just said so you were a model but
then you became an actress
was that a interesting transition for
you and just as I said that Marty's
sitting down where Andy is leaned into
my face and like the audience the
audience couldn't see what he was doing
and it was I'm trying not since she's
like and I'm holding the desk and
practically urinating because it was so
hard and then I get through it and I
said we're gonna take a little break
we'll be right back and they spin starts
playing and I walk around and lean over
to morning Marty and I said I'm trying
to make a living ass that's amazing
you